we bought a house at the beginning of
this year and 2 weeks after we closed on
our house the pipes in the bathroom
burst lost my job recently So currently
my husband is working y need to write a
country song an hour we showered my
mother-in-laws and I lost my job my
husband um he uh had his driver's
license suspended and the car broke down
so we were able to why did he have his
driver's license suspended I can't
believe this it's been suspended for um
for quite a while he had to wait a
couple years um there was a period of
time DUI for the points yeah and then
for the points to fall off okay so your
excuse is you're a full-time driver for
an $18 an hour guy you make more than he
makes yeah and so we were able to share
um we were working in the same town we
were driving yeah back when but now with
him being yeah yeah but now with you not
having a job you used driving him as an
excuse to not get a job so get another
job girl